did ball lightning inform your work with
plasma
i cannot say it did again what informed
it it was was the but that's a very good
question what informed it was this um
idea of
considering the heaviside version of of
maxwell's equation and this idea of that
you can get these extremely high
electromagnetic energy fluxes
but if you look carefully at this
question it's quite possible that that's
why it works that's why for example
it's a very unusual that these uh
these effects could these balls of
plasma can actually go for solid walls
you have to question why
how
you hear people talk about orbs in the
ufo circles do you believe these to be
related to ball lightning or some form
of plasma
i quite believe that there are forms of
plasma yes sir it speaks it speaks to
this idea of quantum electrodynamic
vacuum by breakdown because once you
achieve these effects all these
anomalies can be present yes i do
believe that's possible
just to get a bit speculative here these
balls are usually of the size of the
order of a tennis ball to a basketball
they're generally not larger than a
building let's say so let's speak on the
ones that are small
do you imagine that to be a small craft
a probe
hyper speculation again this is
okay the from a hyper speculation point
of view i would say it's quite possible
these are probes
yes
when
someone is operating in that craft that
you outlined in this
hybrid craft using an inertial maths
hybrid craft using an inertial mass
modification
device
article are you able to control the
craft from within it because in some of
these space-time engineer i know you're
not engineering the metric but in some
of these craft which depend on
space-time metric engineering it's not
as if you can control
the mechanism that propels you forward
so that you can stop it and move it left
and right and so on because it's
causally disconnected from you can you
control it in your model
i believe it's possible again refer to
froning's work and the conditioned
vacuum
once you can achieve these voids within
the vacuum it's quite possible that you
can
affect these uh
think of the craft as being sucked
within these voids within the vacuum
that i created
that's what frowning work talks to
and you can see his work you can i i
believe that
the pdfs of it still available on
if you google them
yeah